every day people around the world spend
16 billion hours on unpaid care work
cooking for their families cleaning up
after them caring for children and older
relatives and all the other routine
household tasks these activities are
happening all day at every hour in every
country around the world but because
many don't get paid for this work most
of us take it for
[Music]
granted care work is a catchall term for
all the tasks and chores that are done
in service of other people some care
work is paid like medicine nursing or
being a nanny but a tremendous amount is
done for free and this unpaid care work
is overwhelmingly done by women there
have been so many women in my own life
Who provided both paid and unpaid care
work my mother and my grandmother before
her isi who's nursing my grandmother in
her final years Patricia who cares for
my children when I travel for work and
I've been an unpaid caregiver too caring
for my immediate family but also
spending several months caring for
ailing friends their children and my dad
in his lost days I've come to realize
that unpaid care work makes all other
work possible during the coid pandemic
with the closure of schools and the
strain on the Health Care System the
amount of time spent on unpaid care and
domestic work doubled for working
parents this has been a disaster for
women around the world compounding the
stress and pushing Millions out of the
paid labor market altogether it set the
clock back on progress by decades but at
the same time the pandemic also made
care work visible it showed up in the
background of our Zoom calls and in our
need to limit overtime and so many
workplaces were able to integrate and
even celebrate this new reality right
now we have an incredible opportunity to
recognize the care work in our lives
reframe it for ourselves and build
workplaces that are much more
accommodating of it and here's where we
can start if you are someone providing
care the biggest thing you can do is
name it for yourself and for others care
work it's not a distraction if you're
fitting it around paid employment you're
not taking a break if you're un
sabatical caring for someone in need
this is real critical work that can be
exhausting frustrating and even boring
give yourself permission to feel all of
the emotions you'd feel if the work came
accompanied by a paycheck and when
you're talking to your manager about it
don't feel like you need to apologize
remember this is a fact of life and be
as explicit as you can about your needs
do you need 3 months at home or do you
need Tuesday Mornings for a standing
appointment as a caregiver it's also
important to recognize the skills that
you gain doing this work there is so
much involved with giving care handling
transport Logistics interpreting medical
charts managing financials these are
valuable skills that are relevant to all
kinds of contexts so if you have a job
frame caregiving to your colleagues that
way and if you're looking for paid work
don't treat it as a big empty Gap Gap in
your life put it on your CV and outline
the skills that you've gained from it
skills like multitasking project
management or communication but of
course it's not just on individuals to
change how The Wider world thinks about
care work we need systemic change from
employers too the biggest thing that
employers can do is to make space for
employees to talk about care work
without being penalized or seen as less
focused or dedicated caregiving should
be a topic that's brought up early when
new employees first start their training
workplaces should track and understand
the kind of care work employees are
responsible for and what kind of policy
changes are needed to make their lives
better and more productive and employers
should make sure that caregivers aren't
passed over for key projects or
promotions just because of their duties
at home caregiving is such a fundamental
aspect of Being Human and yet it's so
artificially cleansed from our work
lives instead of treating it like a
secret workplaces can bring it out into
the open and of course workplaces need
to offer flexibility to accommodate the
lived realities of caregivers for
employees who are parents in addition to
parental leave this means allowing them
time off when kids are sick or home from
school it means letting them establish
dark zones in their calendar around
school drop offs bath time bedtime
rituals and respecting those boundaries
it means offering remote work options
for people caring for elders or those
who are sick or disabled this means
giving them reasonable amounts of leave
it means building projects that are
based on milestones and deliverables
rather than relying on frequent meetings
and check-ins alone it means being
really flexible about when and where the
work gets done and workplaces often
Thrive as a result and one final Point
care work is one of the fastest growing
sectors of our economy as a result of a
growing and an aging population over 2
billion people in the world will need
Care by 2030 this means that the time is
now to shift the way we think about
caring for them this aging population is
going to need support they're going to
need new Solutions this means
Innovations jobs new Industries and
where many other jobs are lost to
automation the one job that we're so
uniquely good at as humans is caring for
other humans